here to tell us more is Olaf bunker from
the European Council on Foreign
Relations welcome to mate in Germany
thank you for being our guest is this
push for privatization really a good
idea to be very honest I have my doubts
because the conditions at the moment are
in the baddest shape I think so we have
a major lost of trust on both sides so
great people lost trust in and hope in a
way in their own economy so the the
creditors lost hope in the case so I am
really i'm looking forward into a very
bad scenario i think so the 50 billion
are in illusion let's talk about those
50 billion just grease even have 50
billion euros worth of assets to sell
here it depends how you calculate this
of course you could on papers say this
is saw the worth in the world is sorries
and they saw that numbers but as I said
so the the conditions at the moment are
that we really are facing a situation
where the cheapest that maybe get to get
the deal and I don't really see how they
can ever achieve this 50 billions
because so if if you don't buy so it's
unlike enough Liam market you get
degrees actually in say okay so give me
a good price and they say no but we have
to achieve 50 billion so nobody would
buy for that so it sounds like you're
saying Athens isn't going to be able to
get a fair price for its commodities
know if you look into the history of
this privatization fund it was
originated in two thousand eleven and
two thousand eleven we already talked
about 50 billion and by today we they
achieved four billion so there's a major
deficit and I don't understand why they
came up with this number again the Greek
government really has its back up
against the wall here though how ironic
is it that the leftists Ariza government
is the one that has to push this
privatization through yeah this is
exactly sort of how you can see how
desperate they are it was not the free
and fair choice the Prime Minister
tsipras made it quite clear in the vote
and evening Wednesday a week ago when he
said so I have to present this to the
Parliament but I'm not behind it so it's
not what we
imagine what we hope for and so
therefore you can see there's a major
lack of ownership and so that's I think
the basis for a very miscalculated deal
what's on the auction block here what's
for sale now so we've seen this so we're
talking about harbors about airports
we're talking about hundreds and
thousands of billions buildings which
are owned by the government but they are
so they try to sell them already since
years and they did not achieved any
major deal so I really have my doubts
that that this kind of assets are very
attractive at the same time we just
heard that the German transit company
fraport wants to buy something in Greece
what are the other potential buyers here
in this scenario yeah so we are talking
about the harbor in Paris and P Rose has
a Chinese competitors so they already
rendered the harbor they will now buy it
so we're talking about Russian companies
who are trying to buy infrastructure in
the energy market so there are interests
from all over the world but again the
question is will they really pay the
price for which the government has to
present to the troika I have my doubts
you can sell anything if the price is
right stay here for a moment were going
to come right back to you